there's a massive new update to the
Bitcoin market and I think you should
pay attention the financial accounting
standard sport the organization that
oversees publicly traded companies they
previously had companies treating
Bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies as an
indefinite lived intangible asset what
the hell does that mean means that if
you held this asset on your balance
sheet you had to Simply Mark the lowest
price it touched in any given quarter if
you bought Bitcoin at fifty thousand
dollars and it dropped to 25 even if it
came back you still had to report that
the Bitcoin was only worth twenty five
thousand dollars that makes no sense and
so now the Financial Accounting
Standards Board has upgraded the rules
they received a ton of pressure from
people like Michael Saylor and companies
like tax bit the Financial Accounting
Standards Board has upgraded those rules
to allow people to use fair market value
that means if you hold 10 Bitcoin on
your balance sheet and the price today
is fifty thousand dollars you simply can
report that you have five hundred
thousand dollars of Bitcoin on your
balance sheet this Common Sense
accounting rule will allow for more
publicly traded companies to buy Bitcoin
and hold it on the their balance sheet
it allows for companies to Simply treat
Bitcoin like what it is a highly liquid
publicly traded asset that simply has a
market value that moves 24 7 365 days a
year these small nuanced seemingly weird
Accounting Standards have a massive
impact on the way public companies think
about what assets they hold on their
balance sheet and it has prevented many
many companies and billions of dollars
from coming into the Bitcoin Market it
won't happen overnight but now that the
Financial Accounting Standards Board has
upgraded these rules I expect more
public companies to put Bitcoin on their
balance sheet especially in an
environment where we are experiencing
8.2 percent inflation in the United
States and it doesn't seem like there's
any relief to the devaluation of dollars
on the horizon